[Music]
congratulations I'm loving everything in
this collection all right so what's your
favorite piece for the Fall this
collection I wanted me to see this on
the runway because I mean I want a
fashion show this is actually one of my
favorite pieces hence why I'm wearing it
but it's actually a jumpsuit it looks
like a two-piece in the front it's just
amazing it's super cute and comfortable
I mean this has three I think we both
were very pieces speaking up fashion
shows Kanye's show today was hot I mean
what was the most epic moment I mean you
guys were sitting there front row what
was it like being there what was your
most favorite part I don't know why I
love Kanye's show
I feel like they're so always super
elevated and cool and they inspire me
and I just don't know I think it was
great
it's always nice seeing his like
creative mind come out Kendall do you
guys do you give your sister's any
advice so when they're walking down the
runway in a show like this no I mean
they've never really asked I feel like
the only time I've ever spoken to you
about it was the Kanye show she walked
in a couple seasons ago she like came
out I went up a backstage to say hi and
she came up to me and she was like what
do I do this person said this to me and
I was like oh my god just be cool
do blondes have more fun than brunettes
so far I think so
[Music]